in a strange coincidence I played a
tournament on Friday and Saturday and I
am played in six months and now I've
played four tournaments in four weeks
and I'm actually going to play next week
in the holiday sixteen chess 16 chess 16
yeah that might be in a couple of days
for you guys at home that'll be at
January 2nd is that right no I think
it's on January 2nd yes chess 16 2016
he's like ah that makes sense it's not
the 16th of January that would that
would make that would make little sense
ok so I played five games one of them
was an end game right away and so I
can't really show you that game because
it was an end game I move 12 so we would
have to master not playing the middle
game that'll be my next lecture so I had
two good middle games in this tournament
so I'll show you both one is against
Wilson Gow and Wilson Gow is a child
who's about this tall okay and used to
play the beginner kids tournaments that
we have here at months a month but he's
been banned because he wins all of them
and there's a rule about what your
rating can be and he's about a thousand
points too high rated for it so he used
to be rated about 700 now he's rated
1600 now he plays an adult tournaments
and I've seen Wilson Gow when I've been
helping out directing the kids
tournaments and he's always on board one
and he's always winning but not allowed
to play anymore
okay and in this position played a very
unusual move well normally black plays
the the nimzo-indian with Bishop to b4
the reason is let's see for our classes
on the ball they don't look like you
can't see them but they look like a
Three Stooges audience if you know what
I mean okay so this position if it were
White's turn to move what would white do
I think they're trying out for the Three
Stooges and getting the part anybody
what would white do here efore yeah II
four is a good move
fact Bishop b4 makes efore look sort of
silly because on the eforp ones hanging
because the knight spin my opponent was
not perturbed by e4 and played b6 so I
applied e4 okay I mastered the middle
game and already White has a significant
advantage if you put it on your engines
it says something like point seven or
point eight for white because white just
says domination of the center d5
fighting for the center now my whole
life these kinds of position that had
similar positions often I always get my
pawn on e5 either by playing e5 now or
by taking and then playing e5 but I
decided to do something different which
the computer doesn't like as much so
shows you that I know and I just kept
taking on d5 and the reason I did that
is funny if we can go back then we can
see told you if we look I was thinking
of the exchange fringe which I've
actually played with white okay and I
like to play lines where you place for
usually I play Knight f3 and then I play
C for but since c4 is explosive let's do
right away Knight f6 93 now can you
imagine black playing b6 in this
position
the answer is fries I mean answer's no
and I would probably take and this is
actually the same position as in the
game and that's what I was thinking
during the game so I was like let's do
that let's get this position that looks
like it's from an exchange French okay
so e5 is a better move and I even
thought e5 was a really strong move but
I was like let's take and see what
happens okay he took back
I played Bishop c4 but he saw it and he
defended his knight and this position I
was playing too quickly but it was game
in 45 so I don't want to take an hour
per move and here I have a very strong
move which I underestimated and
overlooked and I just played the normal
move castles at my opponent Castle but
actually I have a very sneaky move Queen
a4 check and this will shock all of you
at home it won't shock the people here
according to the engine the best move is
King f8 and if my opponent played King
FA
it I would definitely play Queen a for
Chuck okay because on the other hand if
he doesn't play King f8 he has to make
sure he doesn't lose a piece losing a
piece is bad okay for example let's look
at all the other legal moves Queen d7 I
trade and you lose your knight on d5 I
got two attackers you got one defender
so you can't do that if you play C six
your C pawn is pinned your C pawn can't
move so I can take on d5 you can't take
back so you don't want to do that if you
play 96
you're blocking your bishop so again
your Knights not defended and if you
play 97
you're blocking your Queen so once again
I can take the knight on d5 on the only
other legal way
well kb5 is horrible is Bishop c6 and
I'm guessing am i guessing right I was
guessing Bishop b5 although I don't know
why Bishop b5 would be so good you know
it would be good as Queen b3 yeah now I
got a lot of guys attacking your night
if you're night moves away I got you on
f7 on the other hand if I play Queen b3
right away you could play c6 but you
can't play c6 when I play Queen a4 check
and then Bishop c6 because c6 is illegal
so after Queen a4 check the engine says
King f8 is best and if I had realized
that and a lot more than 5 seconds per
move I would have played Queen a4 check
and white has a big advantage instead I
castled and this is sort of the start of
the middle game
I think Queen a4 check is still the
opening and since this is mastering the
middle game I've done nothing wrong in
fact I've never done anything wrong I
can get a lot of ex-wives to tell you
that I've never done anything wrong okay
now in this position I always tell my
students
rooks gone open files and this rook is
not an open file
so I played rook to e1 again that works
great on anyone and he played Knight
takes Knight I took back then he played
97
and now this is actually quite funny I
didn't realize at the time but again I
have sort of a tricky move that I didn't
really fully look at I can play the very
simple
Queenie - and if I was an engine I would
have played Queenie - the idea is I'm
threatening the bishop and the most
natural moves put black and some issues
computer says Bishop d6 is best but
after Bishop g5 obviously White's better
here I'm not even sure what black should
do I guess he could pin his own night
but that's not very good but the main
idea is after Bishop f6 I can play
Bishop a3 and if you play rook e8 I
could even sacrifice on f7 and your king
is going to go for a walk that's
probably okay for black but there was
some other move here that I think it
like better I think it was 95 and I want
to play 95 and then if he trades Knights
it's unclear but if he trades Knights
here he's losing a tempo on his Bishop
so I'm going to get to play e6 and I'm
have pressure here and this is just good
for white and again I didn't I didn't
really look at Queen e2 I was just sort
of playing like I'll do whatever I want
and I'll improve my position slowly but
okay probably when the middle games
started I should have been thinking a
bit bored by what I wanted to do not
just moving quickly okay but I played a
four because I have an isolated a pawn
and I want to train it so I don't have
an isolated a pawn because that's what I
do and I thought my opponent wanted to
play c5 attacking my center but I don't
think he wants to play a five and c5
because then b6 is weak and if you play
if I play a five then I sort of did what
I wanted to do either a6 or take he
played c5 as expected and I played
Bishop a3 hoping for this trade which is
very favorable to white very favorable
okay so obviously he didn't do that he
played Bishop f6 I played a5 as I wanted
to do
and he played rook e8 now when your
opponent as a bishop on the diagonal
with your king
moving your rook away from your F pawn
is not usually the best decision and so
the first thing I thought of when my
opponent played rook e8
is how can i attack f7 so I attacked f7
and I played Queen b3 and I'm
threatening Bishop takes f7 check I was
very happy because my opponent was I
don't know he's nine years old maybe
maybe he's nine and he was playing
faster than me and when I played Queen
b3 then he wasn't playing faster than me
anymore because I was thinking the best
move his rook f8 but what young kid is
going to play rook e8 at rook F a bit
their mistake because you want to defend
your F pawn and after rook F feint
White's better because the C pawn is
pinned again and I just gained two Tempe
I'll put my rook on d1 and all my pieces
are great my opponent thought forever
and played King h8 and if you've watched
my lectures before you know if it's free
it's for me so I took and he played
rookie seven which I didn't see but the
computer likes so I'm a pawn up but my
opponent might play Bishop takes f3 and
ruined my my pawn structure and my
bishop is sort of sitting in his
territory where he can keep attacking it
so I thought I would stop my bishop from
being attacked and stopped the ship f3
so I played Bishop d5 not the computer
recommended move and now he surprised me
by trading everything and basically
getting his pawn back although still
with the worst position and basically
he's always going to be worse because
his King is trapped in the corner and
white doesn't really have any problems
at all but he's getting close to equal
because he got his pawn back he traded
bishops he traded rooks he traded pawns
and he got his pawn back B takes a5
although I mean it's a double isolated
pawn that's blocked by my bishop and my
queen is is pretty nice so I would still
call this a middle game some would call
it an in game the reason I call it a
middle game
is I have attacking chances against his
King and usually in the endgame we're
trying to queen pawns and we did we
didn't try to do that okay
so again the computer doesn't like my
next move it wants me to play move I
didn't look at and when it's show me
that move I was like yeah like that move
wants me to play rook e6 with the idea
of rook g6 yeah I like that's a good
idea I agree with that
but I played h4 because I don't like
getting checkmated so now I get rid of
the back rank issue and now my knight
has G 5 in many instances and maybe
occasionally I'll even attack with my H
pod
ok once again he surprised me but the
computer sort of likes what he did by
trading everything okay making my middle
game lecture look silly because he's
getting to an end game he played Knight
b6 and for those of you at home who
don't see the tactics if we trade
everything I showed this position in my
kids class a few days ago and I said how
does white win and their answers weren't
good they were like rookie 7 rookie 6
rookie three rookie four and I was like
what about all these hanging pieces but
they didn't like any of that okay but I
would take the rook
okay so my opponent give all his pieces
away he played Knight b6 attacking my
queen now I'm a pawn up again and he
surprised me again by taking this pawn
because it looks like I have lots of
tricks but I realized when I was
thinking about how to win tricks are for
kids and him playing a kid so if I play
some normal move like rook d1 which
looks good he'll play Bishop takes F to
check and I'll lose my rook on d1 so I
can't do that so I thought quite a long
time here probably my longest think of
the game because I have a lot of tactics
and I was trying to figure out which
ones worked
I was thinking should i attack his queen
should I play rook e7 should I play
Knight g5 to play Knight f7 in 96 should
I take the bishop and after thinking for
about eight or nine minutes which is a
lot of the game 45 I played Knight takes
Bishop and then I played the move that
will shock the audience although they
already look pretty shocked
okay and this is a big tactical move and
before I make such a move I have to
think several minutes to make sure it
doesn't lose all my pieces because it's
pretty scary okay and I think the
computer wants me to play Bishop c5 here
and says whites better
although the computer often goes into
these drawn endgame as it says whites
better but I'm not going into those so I
played the brilliant tactical move which
Jenny found right away for white he just
walked in so that's tough he thought you
just walk in and watch the class but
he's been quizzed right away I played
Queen takes a seven now obviously if he
takes my queen I'll play rook to the
back rank me but that wasn't the point
the point was I take upon some pawn
ahead and the other point is I have a
threat and my threat is if I could move
again but all you have a threat what
they can't believe it all the way in the
back
illegal that's a yeah right Queen takes
rook check and Ricky gave me so if black
plays some really scary move like Queen
c3 that doesn't stop my threat of Queen
takes rook check okay so he thought a
long time here which is good if they
move instantly that means they saw your
trick and they they're punishing you any
plate h6 so he wouldn't get checkmated
and when I played Queen a7 I you that I
had two moves here to save my Queen and
I played this slightly trickier one and
the slightly better one Queen f7 I could
also play Queen e7 now after rook takes
Bishop I could try to checkmate him with
rook e8
but trying is the first step to failure
I would just check and take his rook and
this position I know I could win okay so
my opponent played another move that
shocked me and the computer doesn't like
it he played Queen takes h4 okay if you
just walked in you might think well
material is equal the bishop on a3 is
almost hanging this looks like a draw
okay now I have a rule for my
and students much more advance the
people in this room and so much better
than you at home you get to be one of
the top ten players in the world at home
and only like six of you are watching
the other four playing in Qatar okay so
I know that they're not watching okay so
Magnus is taking the day off from
watching my lecture because he's playing
a he can't be twenty-three twenty-four
hundred all right and one of my rules
for all of my students again you have to
be top ten in the world Queen and Bishop
are better than Queen and Knight and a
lot of people will tell you the opposite
okay that's why I like to play them okay
and here we really see the advantage of
the Queen and Bishop obviously depends
on the position but here the bishop
really crushes the knight and queens xh4
was a mistake my opponent had a queen
unperfect position and instead he got
greedy and let my bishop come to its
fruition so Queen h4 losing and now I
play Bishop to b2 threatening checkmate
with advantage okay and it's hard to
stop the checkmate especially with this
silly night that Knights not stopping
checkmate and now once again my opponent
thought for a long time and I thought he
would play Queen g5 or queen g4 I was
correct for once and now I play rook e6
which I should have played a few moves
earlier as discussed but now when I play
it's even better
okay and my opponent has one good move
here where whites only +4 is a fantastic
move which I didn't see and I'd only be
+4 but you didn't find it does anybody
see blacks best to move you're playing a
lot of 1-minute chess you've got to find
moves like this because you can still
win when you might as for absolutely.we
he played you can't win then you can
never be anybody what's the best move
for black very difficult question I know
I didn't know the answer I thought he'd
resign but I was wrong as usual let's
see who knows the answer what's the best
move who can do it anyone you with the
wrong answer yeah
yeah Queen g5 is the wrong answer that's
probably like the third best move that's
pretty good that's good enough yeah
my opponent made the slight mistake rook
d8 only one person left he who laughs
last didn't get the joke you with the
crazy answer yeah you want him to play
rook k1 Jace yeah
then check and then take my bishop yeah
that I mean you're losing all your
pieces but yeah well rook takes Knight
would win but if you were a super
grandmaster what you're gonna play
rookie hate yeah I'm going to play here
I'm a super grandmaster because then
that's annoying you know what I'm saying
he's like yeah yeah
although rook e8 winds rook takes Knight
wins and your move is better than what
my opponent did but it's not good enough
it's better okay my opponent played 95
or rip d8 I mean and then I played
checkmate with advantage yeah then the
game is over because I won okay well you
should have played is King H 7x clam
getting out of the pin then I have to
take his knight then he could like
pretend to threaten something right
that's pretty good since his movie to
actually be winning rook check Queen h4
mate yeah so that was the best he could
do but and also I think the computer
wants me to play half three here which I
would never do never play off three okay
and then this is the best he could do
but instead he hung natan one he was
threatening made himself it was black to
play he would meet me okay if I took his
Knight that he would check me me rook d1
and queen inch more but I knew I was
threatening checkmate so I won that game
so even though it looks like an end game
I still call it a middle game because I
have a big attack there's a lot of
pieces on the board and more importantly
that's the name of the lecture mastering
the middle game you guys showed up early
late
so you'll be like class egging the
middlegame not mastering because you
missed the first you know yeah okay now
the other game which was sort of a
middle game was this one I had the black
pieces now this is a local player Steve
bang who's always rated about 1970 I
don't know how he does it
thousand every thousand games is the
same reading every after every round if
he wouldn't it's still the same reading
and the first time I played him I was
white and I got nothing like it was a
draw game ended in a draw and a thousand
moves I was were supposed to the game
with white then I played him again I
beat him in a million Woo's with black
the games got longer okay and in this
scheme it looked like it was going to
happen again another five million movie
game but instead he made like 30
mistakes in a row so now for those of
you who watch all my lectures which is
obviously all of you you'll remember my
game with Matt Barrett which I lectured
on a couple weeks ago from the club
championship yeah that sounds right okay
and actually we played the same
everything the same okay this is my game
with matt baer which i've already
lectured on you might have just watched
that lecture and in my game with matt
baer and I was like d4 what kind of move
is that
that's the fifth most common move I
don't know that move well my opponent
played it again so I played the Matt
Barrett you know defense and here good
players play BC okay but that's an old
move BC yeah okay and I'm more into like
Marvel so I play DC okay good and when I
played Matt Barrett and I played DC I
was like that's a dumb move I was like
really ashamed after I played it then I
looked at with my engine engine says DC
good move and I was like all right and
super grandmasters always play DC but
I'm only a regular Grandmaster okay now
for those of you who remember my
lectures Matt Barrett played Bishop e2
and a tradition e to 9 g6 he quickly
made a move that I thought was bad
Knight c3 and the reason is the knight
can't go anywhere and in fact he ended
up going back to b1 later
which Greg shoddy would approve of
okay and during the game with with Matt
Barrett when I played DC I was like oh
no eventually that is going to go to c4
and that's very annoying
but then when you play dice III I was
pretty happy okay so my opponent played
Bishop d3 not Bishop u2 and then
immediately played 92 okay he knew what
to do
okay or as they say on Futurama he know
what do know don't sue me okay so II 594
back and I thought white should try to
get his Knight to f5 but my opponent did
not agree
you play Bishop III now the Knights not
going to go to f5 okay so now it's sort
of boring the computer says equal okay
in my opponent played a four now this is
something I like quite a bit from the
mastering the middle game lecture
standpoint this was the opening we're
done with the opening now it's the
middle game now one thing that I
concentrate on that my opponents don't
so if you ever play me forget what I'm
saying now is I think about what my
opponent is going to do and how do I
stop it
my opponents can play a five and then I
can't move any of my pawns because I'll
get crushed and I was like I don't want
to play a five but if I play a five then
he puts one of his pieces on b6 I don't
want to do that so I thought about
playing b5 myself but the problem is
takes takes he could play some crazy
move like Knight b6 and I'm too old for
that
I can't let things like that happen okay
so I played b5 but not not quite
b6 okay now my opponent plays a5
I can play b5 and then I don't really
care so much this night has to move
backwards and my opponent made where I
consider the first mistake probably the
most logical looking moving the position
but you didn't study the position deeply
played where k d1 now when you play one
of your routes to d1 you should have a
plan for your other rook this rook
already has a plan the a pawn was moved
okay the rook on f1 where's that going I
mean it's going to e1 then back to f1
question because it's hanging what's
your rating all right yeah so let's look
at the Dania Machuca variation Danny
sacrifices a piece because I tell them
to always sacrifice a piece you're
supposed to say you told me never to
sacrifice the fees right okay and and I
could play queen bee seven or queen bee
a you're down a piece you're pretty high
rated what do you think blacks up a
piece you have a passed pawn for a piece
when you kappa blanka you lookin I'm
talking about you don't think I'm
talking about
no well putting on your injury if you
engine says why it's better you got me
you got me
if you sack a piece against you and you
beat me I just clap and the last person
who beat me sacked appease and beat me
and that was who's the last person being
in a tournament game - for 13 months who
did it and you want Sam Savion sack to
piece computer so I was slightly better
than you beat me I mean if you sack a
piece of beat me or you're too good okay
if you sack a piece I'm off a piece
that's that's great okay by the way Matt
Barrett shifts acted piece against me
but he would've got in three or four
points okay
that's a reality Rick ad one and now I
shocked the world okay if you thought
you know Ollie beating you know now in
that Frazier Liston he's not that
shocked the world if you thought the guy
who beat Tyson who yeah but if you now
you just see something shakes up the
world that was just preparing you for
this position okay
after b6 Rick d1 now I played the
shocking move neither too shocked b5 see
when his rook was on a one I didn't like
b5 now is Rick's not on a1 now I like b5
because
he trades Knight b6 is let is not
possible unless you're dating Machuca
then maybe because I get a nice laid
upon alright but if his rook was on a1
the 96 is reasonable okay
also I didn't think you should take my
pawn but computer agreed with him okay
he went back to d2 I don't have to play
a six but I did because if he takes on
b5 I could take on c2 but I like my pawn
on b5
okay now mastering the little game I
don't know about that that's mastering
passivity that's the next class those
pieces can do anything yeah in fact can
any of can this Bishop move could this
Bishop move you know what's he doing
over here why is this work on d1 so it
could be blocked by two pieces now
you'll like this after I yeah he played
rook a one so he played rook but that
rook isn't done they went to do you want
you'll see okay Bishop to e6 I know you
wanted feeing kettle your Bishop but I
like my bishop here because I'm trying
to protect c4 I think if you play c4 you
can equalize if he doesn't play it I
think this one's just weak okay rook c1
and I made a joke in the kids class
which I don't think was recorded so I
can make the joke again except that's
not a joke it's the problem you all know
being the fine players that you are no
sarcasm at all that rooks gone open
files rooks want lots of space and when
you intentionally move your rook behind
a pawn we have a name for that in
Michigan there's a player of Michigan
does that a lot as a Class A player his
name's Tom manion's we call it a Mannion
rook so if you're watching this that's
named after you okay not Josh Mannion
Josh Mannion was an IM in the 90s he's
not named after him okay so he wants to
play c4 and he wants to see pawn really
well defended good for him
rook GA now if you move your C pawn
you're unde offending you know your
piece here on d3 so it's sort of risky
and he played Knight f3 I assume to play
Knight g5 or Bishop g5 so I said no
you're not doing that h6 again I don't
like when my opponents do stuff so
they can do it my opponent copycatted h3
which is fine and I played Bishop c5 now
in this position I wanted to play Knight
f4 which I did in the Matt Barrett game
if you were paying attention but then he
would take my knight
I think suggested by Dani Machuca in the
last class and then e 5 and then Queenie
for Queen age 7 and I to resign and then
you don't get to see this game but if
his bishops not on III and it's off the
board see how good I am
let's took it off the board now 19 f4 is
looking pretty good
so I said Bishop c5 let's trade bishops
and then I'll play Knight f4 and he said
his don't think so Bishop d2 of I like
what his pieces move backwards okay now
again I want to play Knight f4 I don't
want to take it with the bishop
so I played Queen e7 I'm going to play
Queen f6 then play Knight f4 that I'll
take with the Queen okay now my opponent
confused me he made a move I never would
have thought of okay he shouldn't do
that I'm trying to play chess over here
he played Knight h2 and I'm assuming of
I don't know for a fact if I play Queen
f6 he was going to attack my Queen and
then maybe as I would go to e3 and he
could go to f5 again on the other hand I
have a rule that I teach all my students
I listen to when I my own rules when
your opponent makes a move whatever they
moved is it where it was it's where it
went to you can write that down okay
that night on h2 is it where it was
where was it f3 what was it doing on f3
it was protecting the center now I can
go to d4 which by the way looked pretty
good to me because I sort of wanted to
do that okay if you play c3 that's very
dangerous because all your pieces are
hanging I could play Bishop f2 if I was
in a crazy mood okay then we could get
some crazy variation like this okay I
wasn't in a crazy mood although after
this I'm in a crazy mood so yeah so I
get my piece back and I went upon so c3
Peter doesn't like on the other hand
allowing this is sort of risky so he did
a double Mannion not recommended by me
on the other hand allowing that's not
also not good so what did he do
yeah he played Rick a 2 B 1 because that
rube didn't move enough yet okay and I
put my rook on an open file and he
kicked my bishop away and I'm like all
right and he did it again Britney Spears
style Rick a1 if you just walked up to
the game now would you think white
played rugby one rook a 1 would be one
rook a 1 the answer is fries okay so I
defended my pawn and the thing is these
pieces really haven't done anything
and my bishops on a nice diagonal my
rooks are on open files he's got to
watch out for Knight f4 what's that yeah
my bishops are pretty good yeah that's
right they're much better than the the
rap group criss cross even though the
are crisscrossing okay too confusing for
the kids in the audience now my opponent
made the worst move ever I should tell
you a story I didn't tell the kids class
cuz too complicated Fischer lost a
famous game I think it was - a little
mama vibin if akov butt's the one of
them unless I'm wrong then it's somebody
else and Fischer was going to play like
h6 like just normal h6 like I did
however h6 just hung the H pawn because
there was some pin so he put the pawn
back on h7 and you had to play h5 the
worst move ever
because h6 hung material and then he
lost the game because h5 made no sense
okay my opponent intentionally did that
so worse than Fischer so if you're
taking notes at home this 1900 players
worse than Fischer and in fact they
played right now would be clause okay
and my opponent made the worst move okay
and I think he sort of lost his sense of
danger he was like well Ben's playing
Bishop d4 to b6 and Queen moving back
and forth everything moving back and
forth he wasn't worried at all he
decided to get aggressive now if you put
this petition on an engine it prefers
black because my bishops are better than
his my
better than is and my nights better than
his my night might go to f4 his night
could retreat to some silly square okay
my opponent blundered with h4 okay that
loses the game okay
and I don't know why but I was really
brutal at this point like I actually
played well it's that good when I play
well you shouldn't expect that when
you're playing me and when your opponent
plays h4 this is the first rule you
think of and I played it Dania Machuca
all right just tell them the answer now
9h for that smells bad anyone nh4 smells
bad
anyone know NH for nothing how about you
at home I make the joke a lot you should
get it by now
no nobody knows what ammonia is all
right you yeah Bishop g4 now the best
move his resigns but he couldn't find it
I like my kids class they suggested h5
saving the H pawn and I was like my
bishops on g4 what okay so here any good
player would resign Professor Magnus
Carlsen he'd resign he's like sorry I
didn't see mr. g4 no and then I'd be
like that's okay you'll you'll be better
later in your life
alright so how did he save his age pawn
g3 huh terrible move by the way but
saves his H pawn okay now as I said in
the kids class which wasn't recorded
this is a gen Shahada position those are
few and far between because she doesn't
play anymore
but gen Shahaji likes one thing in chess
it's not checkmate it's not taking a
queen it's not beating Magnus Carlsen
there's one thing that she likes she
likes Rovers especially because she
handed her over okay a Rover is when you
move your hook up and over wrote Rover
see if you spoke French should get it
okay so this Knight needs to be attacked
by her over and so that's what I did
rook c6 with the idea of rook
six followed by white resins that the
kids class asked there the answer is yes
it makes a very slight difference this
is a little bit better
you'll see why about two moves now if
you are white here what would you do
about this impending rook f6 how do you
save your knight the kids clashes play
King g2 and gave their Queen away and
said so what you with the right answer
that's what happened now you sir would
you like your rook on see it or d8 here
that's what I thought
now you see why rook c6 was better
yeah now the old me which coincidentally
was the young me would just take
everything and I've two pieces for a
ruck right but the old me which is me
because I'm old is I want to maintain
the pressure I don't want to do nothing
so obviously I could just take take take
take take take take take take and I have
pieces and you don't takes takes takes
take what do you mean were you beeping
at before okay I have a bishop of the
night for a rock and then magnus carlsen
would resign every move you just feel
like I resign you've two pieces for rook
also man look at this I wouldn't let him
resign because look at this this is
great okay so I didn't want to do that
because that makes too much sense I want
to get more pressure so I play Queen
takes e4 I got a lot of guys on your
knight and I still got this pin and I
got this just in case okay so you got to
save your knight or try to anyway
rook a3 defending is I actually didn't
see their move I was shocked that rook
moved again okay now in the middle game
you want to have an idea I've done most
of my ideas and now I have an extra pawn
well you have an extra pawn you'd like
to use it so I want to play e4 okay
which is somewhat illegal but if I could
play he for that would be a good move so
I play Queen b7 threatening efore good
luck stopping it okay
I showed this position come on think of
his name it makes the joke good edit all
this out
who's the guy in the stupid taken movies
yeah
Liam Neeson I asked Liam Neeson like
what do you think applies position and
he said good luck that was the other guy
who said it but you get the joke anyway
Aviva if you're watching that was for
you alright so e4 and it's all over
any good player would resign but instead
you give all his pieces away which was
fun for me so he played c4 which is
explosive very good and I play d4 and
now he planted who I would never think
of in my life I know the move and I
still can't think of it
if you guessed every legal movie
wouldn't get it now I had a game with
Mario a few weeks ago I sat yesterday
and I said if you look at every legal
move you won't find what Mario did and
he guessed a few moves and gave up and I
showed him and he was like wow I
wouldn't guess that I said I don't know
that's legal I can't even believe it
okay and this is the same this move I I
can't I can't guess this move of course
I was expecting resigns every move
because I'm taking everything if the
knight moves away f2 is hanging although
I'm not sure where your Knights moving
anyway he played Queen c2 okay so I took
her Knight and he played Bishop g3 now
we're a piece up and my favorite piece
is this one because that one's going to
do something mean but he's going to play
C 5 so I play Bishop to d4 and now my
piece is there and you played c5 anyway
okay now I played four tricks because my
opponent was older than me so I'm the
kid now okay and if you saw my game with
Doug Eckhart from years ago you'll
remember I played Queen Tigs g3 check
and he resigned in a very similar
position
so I played Queen c7 threatening Queens
g3 check now we'll see who raises their
hand how do you prevent Queen g3 check
yeah nobody's hand goes up because they
don't want to answer King H to then
obviously Bishop f2 is annoying right
when he's down to piece and he's getting
mated and this is actually very funny uh
if you if you have some time at home
there was a game played I'm going to say
three years ago I'm within a year the
gay man on sheer of and it was a
Cambridge Springs so easy to find on
your database or if you go to like chess
games calm and that game Anand was
attacking his opponent I think I done
sacrificed a piece and all of she Rob's
pieces are on the other side of the
board so that attacked worked she Rob's
King ran around he resigned okay and
this is very similar except I'm up a
piece my opponent's pieces are all in
the Queen side and his King is over here
by himself and all of my pieces are
attacking his king except one I'll
rectify that in a second give me a
second
so he played King f1 okay now most of
you here would play Bishop h3 check
obviously if he goes back he's walking
into me and then he his King is going to
go for a walk riki one check and okay
terrible for white terrible okay but I
want to play Bishop age three check not
along the play King he won okay I want
him to resign so I got my last piece
into the attack Paul Morphy style you
rikiei
right now my rook is stopping his king
and now I mentioned shear off earlier
the game that he lost to Anand I want to
mention him again I believe he was
playing tabla but I could be wrong he
played the most famous Bishop h3 ever
until now and if you know the endgame
I'm talking about that was funnier than
you guys realize you're thinking I'm
talking about
you're the worst you have to shove h3
right the greatest we've ever maybe yeah
okay so if you're at home you already
know this but look up top alive sheer up
maybe 10 years ago
Bishop h3 five years ago Bishop H this
ship and pawn endgame giving his Bishop
way for nothing opposite bishops very
famous game you could go to the Internet
and probably type in shear off Bishop h3
I'm not even kidding probably pop right
up
yeah probably would come up yeah okay so
my opponent played Bishop a5 attacking
my queen oh no okay so this should be a
ch3
check my rook on Yeats doing a good job
and he didn't have the stomach for king
g1 darn after king g1 I would play
Bensimon right with a small attack
followed by mate now during the game I
was considering playing Frank Marshalls
favourite move Levitsky Marshall 1923 my
wake-up was it 23 or 32 yeah one of them
ah Queen G 3 very good
yeah I think in Queen G 3 then if he
takes it Bishop H 3 yeah that's Queen G
3 that's the only similarity like dish
of h3 the only similarity we share a
vision of h3 okay so Queen G 3 would win
but that's when I was younger
okay here this should be h3 is actually
better because my Punk apply the
brilliant dish of efore and his King
escapes and white would eventually win
no now he would eventually not win okay
so Queen g3 wins and I saw up a Bishop
h3 I don't have to sack my queen so I'm
like I'm not doing that and my opponent
resign now that was a really good game
for a middle game lecture because we had
the same pieces in the same pawn
structure but the piece activity was
quite different
his rooks weren't as good his bishops
weren't as good and eventually his King
safety was it as good because of the
move Bishop d2 and I I think the reason
why had a big downfall this game from
like slightly worse to losing other than
the crazy move h4 is in this position I
really don't like them with Bishop to D
- because my Bishop on c5 is okay that's
the answer bishop
digit on c5 is too strong okay and
obviously h4 is totally losing move but
he's worth much worse here engines give
black a big advantage whereas here they
give black a small advantage but
retreating your bishop and letting my
bishop be so strong with lots of
attacking ideas not very good well I
hope you enjoyed those games as much as
I do
if ever plenty but
over 2000 I'm in a lot of trouble this
is grandma Esther been Feingold for
mastering the middlegame we're going to
change the name of the class to grand
mastering the middlegame okay until we
have been Simon teacher okay bye
everyone